you're basically the face of the gaming
industry right now Loki so it's kind of
major yeah I know this is a stop at your
big to sweet man
no I'm just here to just celebrate an
awesome moment for for gaming being on
national television for you know like a
me you know award show Tyler Blevins aka
ninja hitting the red carpet at the
third annual gamers Choice Awards on
Monday one night after going live on
Twitch with rapper lil yachty I have to
go right to this question cuz I've been
dying to know what was on your phone
when ninja was streaming and he looked
over and he was just so sure I was gonna
it's the I was on his chicks Instagram
page and I think she was like just kind
of half naked they just looked over at
the craziest time so much has happened
for you especially the past year but
looking back is there one thing that
really sticks out to you is like I'm
most proud of this I was most proud of
ever hosting my first ever event and in
Las Vegas I've never ever hosted a show
like that before and you know we broke
my own viewer record on Twitch which was
like six hundred sixteen thousand
concurrent viewers over half million
people watching one stream it was
incredible that's definitely my favorite
accomplishment this year
I really want to talk to you about ninja
works because it seems pretty pretty
epic yes no dude the album is incredible
man we've recently launched right now
there's Alesso taiko and Blau and then
we have so many other other I think I
almost say we have Nero coming out soon
and and a lot of other incredible
artists the full album releases on the
14th and the list of the artists are on
the 10th so I mean any chance at the
Drake collapse I hope so
5k don't know if you get this dolphin
enjoy hear me I try hard enough
obviously the big stream with Drake
earlier this year and you roasted
Drake's fortnight's kills a while back
has he gone any better has he learned
anything from ninja at all no that's a
good question
I wouldn't know any better yeah your
boys going it now you're going your boy
how do you still make it fun and fresh
for you to play it as much as you do and
stream it all the time absolutely it's
easy man the game so it's so incredible
it's ever-changing man they're always
adding any weapons and updates to the
map so you know I wake up and there's
something that I haven't read about
that's in the game and it's it's it's
always exciting that it doesn't you know
epic ascent an incredible job of
continuing to evolve a short attention
span society in gaming and and they're
just constantly adding new things and
that's that's it's easy it's not hard at
all
you
[Music]